herzlich willkommen
ich freue mich sehr dass die
sternstunden mich für diesen herbst als
gastmoderator ausgewählt haben
auf das erste gespräch freue ich mich
besonders auf den tag genau heute vor 15
jahren schlugen zwei gekidnappte
passagierflugzeuge in den türmen des
world trade centers in new york ein
die attentate des 11 september 2001
markieren einen wendepunkt der jüngeren
geschichte
sie konfrontierten die bewohner der
westlichen welt mit einer neuen form des
terrors mit einer neuen form der gewalt
nicht zuletzt zog mit ihnen ein lang
verabschiedeter begriff wieder in unser
politisches sprechen ein das böse war
wieder da wobei hat es uns überhaupt
jemals verlassen
betrachtet man die daten war es
jedenfalls kein zufall dass es sich auch
bei den attentätern von nine eleven
ausschließlich um männer handelte die
überwältigende mehrzahl von terrorakten
kriegsverbrechen und gewalttaten wurden
und werden weltweit von männern begangen
woran liegt das hat das böse ein
geschlecht diesen ebenso hochaktuellen
wie philosophisch dunklen fragen möchte
ich heute mit meinen gästen nachgehen
und sie herzlich begrüßen das ist zum
einen job barofsky sie sind professor
für geschichte osteuropäische geschichte
an der humboldt-universität berlin
gewaltforschung haben sich in vielen
publikationen mit den bedingungen und
möglichkeiten von gewaltexzessen
auseinandergesetzt
zu meiner rechten joe bausch sie kennen
ihn als gerichtsmediziner im kölner
tatort joseph roth aber herr bausch hat
noch ein anderes vielleicht sogar
wichtigeres leben nämlich als
gefängnisarzt in der vollzugsanstalt
wäre in deutschland wo sie seit 30
jahren die gefangenen medizinisch
betreuen hat sich willkommen
herr bausch ich habe sprach er davon
dass mit dem nine eleven event diesem
ereignis etwas neues etwas böses in
unsere welt getreten ist das ist
geschichtlich vielleicht richtig aber
wir haben ja auch alle eigenen
biografien eigene leben und es gibt den
zeitpunkt in der kindheit worden
vielleicht begreift so ist das böse so
fühlt es sich an es hat dieses gesicht
gab es solch ein erlebnis in ihrer
kindheit gehalt ist also die erste
vorstellung vor dem bösen hat mir mein
großvater vermittelt wir spielten dann
oder eine bundesstraße die mitten durchs
dorf gilt und es kam ein damals vor
allem einer dunkel gekleidet die hat
eine dunkle klamotten dunkelrot also
kleinen koffer dabei das waren menschen
die hat von a nach b gingen weil es ist
einfach die in fast nur noch nicht gab
und er war freund und dann sagte man
costa kommen das ist ein böser mann
kommt rein
und das hat sich ganz oft wiederholt
auch meine tante michael dazu zu sagen
kommt rein
also das fremde dieser fremde mann den
man nicht kannte in diesem dorf mit
knapp 800 seelen die gegen brasilien das
war das geld das war das böse das war
ein böser mann hat ski haben ja schon
dieser kleinen geschichte glaube ich
sehen wir deutlich dass es eine art
muster gibt das fremde wird mit dem
bösen assoziiert und der mann ist das
für sie als historiker ein kulturell
stabiles vielleicht sogar ein ewiges
muster des menschen dass man das fremde
mit misstrauen betrachtet das glaube ich
ganz natürlich das ist nichts
ungewöhnliches ist es selbst
schutzmechanismus man weiß nicht wer der
andere ist und wenn mal in einer
fragilen umgebung sich befindet denn der
mann nicht sicher sein kann ob man vor
gewalt geschützt wird sind fremde immer
diejenigen die potenziell das böse
repräsentiert weil man nicht weiß was
man von ihnen erwarten kann
in unseren kontext in dem wir uns
bewegen haben wir das problem nicht wir
können fremden offen begegnen weil wir
wissen oder annehmen können dass uns
nichts passieren wird wenn wir uns mit
ihnen ein lassen ob das böse männlich
ist da habe ich meine zweifel dass das
so ist
immanuel kant
hat ja gesagt dass der mensch radikal
böse ist und er hat das so verstanden
dass menschen zwar wissen was vernünftig
ist dass sie sozusagen die selbst
gesetzten prämissen erfüllen müssen
rational handeln sollen
dass sie sich aber immer dagegen
entscheiden können man kann ich kann ich
weiß dass es unvernünftig ist wenn ich
jetzt auch stehe und sie schlagen aber
ich könnte es jederzeit tun wenn ich es
will und dazu sind frauen wie männer
imstande es zu tun weil wir uns alles
vorstellen können wir können uns alles
vorstellen
nur die ausprägung der gewalt die ist
sicher verschieden zwischen männern und
frauen aber dass das böse männlich sein
soll ergibt für mich eigentlich könnte
sie sprachen es ja schon an das böse ist
auch immer eine entscheidung das hat mit
der menschlichen freiheit zu tun
und solch eine entscheidung verlangt der
manchmal auch mut ich erinnere mich an
susan sontag die amerikanische
publizistin die kurz nach nine eleven
gesagt hat über diese attentäter
feiglinge waren sie nicht ist das
richtig braucht man um wirklich böses zu
tun auch mut oder ist das böse er eine
funktion der angst das hängt ganz davon
ab in welchem kontext sie böses tun wenn
sie böses tun in einer umgebung in der
abweichendes verhalten bestraft wird
dann ist es mutig es zu tun sich selbst
umzubringen ist immer mutig aber zum
beispiel andere menschen zu töten
zuschlagen zu verstümmeln und zu
verletzen ist dann mutig wenn man weiß
dass man ein großes risiko eingeht wenn
aber in einer umgebung alle töten
verletzten verstümmeln und das moralisch
auch gar nicht mehr negativ konnotiert
ist dann verhält man sich konform
also man kann als gewalttäter oder als
jemand der böses tut sich konform
verhalten das wissen wir aus der aus der
ns geschichte aus dem stalinismus aus
dem syrischen bürgerkrieg wenn wir die
ses kämpfer anschauen
die gleichen menschen die hier sich nun
konform verhalten würden verhalten sich
dort konform weil ist auch darum geht
dass man überleben muss in einem gewalt
kontext ich glaube dass man das wirklich
von einem kontext von einer situation
abhängig machen soll
zu entscheiden ob jemand mutig handelt
oder ob es nicht tut
auch sie haben ja tagtäglich mit
menschen zu tun die böses getan haben
die gewalt angetan haben
wie denken diese menschen über ihre
eigene tat nach ihrer erfahrung prahlen
sie damit sind sie gekümmert darüber
verfluchen sie sich ist eine reflexion
über die eigene tat im gang die man auch
moralisch nennen kann
also muss vorweg zu nehmen ich glaube
die reflektion über die tat die man auch
als moralische reflektion beschreiben
könnte die selbst relativ spät ein weil
nach der tat dass man hasst man damit
beschäftigt zu verlegt und zu
bagatellisieren dazu zu erzählen wie man
es gemeinden gerne vor gericht oder
wieder anwalt einen berater muss wie man
es darstellen sollte nach meiner
erfahrung kommt es oftmals wirklich
viele monate oder jahre später der
discos der inneren diskurs darüber was
habe ich moralisch falsch gemacht aber
es kommt bei einigen es gibt auch sogar
situationen wo empfunden werde das ist
so durchgangs zustand nämlich dass immer
das ist nicht lange fix das geht dann
wieder weg mit der zeit habe ich bereue
das ist das was ihr wolltet jetzt habe
ich doch getan
jetzt muss doch eine konsequenz daraus
kommen hat man gelernt dass auch ein
reflex wenn ich etwas böses was ich
getan habe bereue mein kind dann ist man
müsse auch wieder versöhnung kommen also
insofern ist es immer ein
durchgangsstadium die der umstand wie
menschen dort ob sie prahlen
das kommt darauf an mit wem sie es zu
tun natürlich sind sie alle gut beraten
niemandem gegenüber mit ihren taten zu
planen die am samstag hat ja eine
unverschämtheit also jemand der mir
gegenüber sitzt sondern hatte sie
erwarte von die einstimmung treue und
dass du ganz kleine brötchen backen ja
da wird keiner prahlen ich weiß
natürlich dass dann wird man unter den
kriminellen es war unter einem
angrenzenden aufziehen möchte wenn es
einfach nutzen es dem anderen zu
bedeuten glaubt ja nicht dass ich so
eine kleine maus
ich kann so was und böse sein ich kann
gemeinsam weil es dir wieder sicherheit
verschafft weil die androhung von
schlimmeren hier wieder sicherheit gibt
da wird gefeiert ganz sicher mit den
taten des kiesabbaus schutz und dann
würde ich gibt es tat mit dem man besser
nicht parat
das ist ein kindern vergeht weinkeller
und bringt uns warte gilt auch unter
diesen bedingungen ja als jemand der
tool ist am besten gar nicht darüber
spricht oder zumindest vorgibt dass er
was anderes getan hat tut oder sowas
aber natürlich es kommt immer auf den
kontext an ja mit wem bin ich zusammen
und was erzählen die geschichten dem ja
es gibt ja von 500 welcher dieses schöne
buch über soldaten werden über das töten
das handwerk des tötens soldaten in
britischer kriegsgefangenschaft abgehört
wurden deutsche kriegsgefangene die
unter sich waren und ermittelt mit ihren
taten geprahlt weil weil sie für
einander gar keine geheimnisse haben
mussten aber die gleichen männer hätten
in ihren familien nicht darüber
gesprochen wie sie zivilisten umgebracht
haben juden erschossen haben das alles
hätten sie wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nicht getan und vor gericht schon gar
nicht da hätten sie sich sicher
präsentiert als jemand der befehle
befolgen muss das unabänderliche tun
musste oder ein überzeugter
nationalsozialist gewesen sei und nicht
erkannt habe dass das böse ist was man
tut
aber das ist leider die situation in der
die öffentlichkeit vom bösen
mitteilungen bekommt die situation vor
gericht wo es um die rechtfertigung geht
und sie haben ganz richtig gesagt wenn
man einen anderen kontext anschaut wo
kriminelle unter sich sind
dann wird anders geredet locker lassen
sie uns doch mal ganz konkret damit wir
auch wissen wovon wir sprechen einen
kontext besichtigen in form eines
dokumentarfilms thorberg heißt dieser
film ist über eine gerichts eine
vollzugsanstalt in der schweiz bei bern
von dieter fahrer und dort denken und
sprechen gefangenen über ihr verhältnis
zu sich selbst und ihrer situation
[Musik]
gut
er widerrief vorgereiht mann der wie ya
konan back for me vermietet do something
bahn vermieter rostock in kuusamo die
was haben keine tilmann fischer sowie
tor ist also ja ja ja fast so wie in die
klasse aus
[Musik]
worin liegt für sie die absurdität des
gefängnisses von der hier zu ende die
rede war
das ist der letzte satz dieses
gefangenen sagt man will uns bessern
aber auf der anderen seite ist die
tatsache dass man zahlt eben doch über
viele jahre in gefängnissen unter
projekt antworten sinne von sühne genau
das was dazu führt dass verdi wieder fuß
fassen können in einer normalen
gesellschaft insofern ist ab die
absurdität das was wir rehabilitation
oder welche sozialisation lernen also
einem sozialen gefüge was dich ja nicht
mehr will was dauerhaft ausstößt
das kann ja nicht behaupten dass wieder
willkommen sein könnte das jemals und
das hat sich gerade in der letzten zeit
gegen ich arbeite der letzten paar sich
ja noch mal deutlich verschärft in der
gesellschaft vor 30 jahren hatte man
noch aussicht doch mal wieder irgendwo
einzusteigen aber heute kann man sagen
okay ich habe mein leben verwirkt also
ich komme ich komme vielleicht nochmal
in so eine grauzone der gesellschaft wo
man so an da kein zu der illegalität
leben kann oder ich verweile in der
illegalität weil ich wusste dass
einsprüche alles was er mir erzählt denn
letztendlich sprüche auf die bitte nicht
einfach
sollten eines muss ich noch sagen ist
natürlich der film natürlich habe ich da
bestimmte behördliche ist kaputt die
goldkette also viele von diesen jungs
die halt natürlich der wahnsinn der
testosteron geschwängerte die geschichte
haben es gibt doch die klein es gibt die
gefährlichen die großen jungs tun mir
nix die großen jungs zu gehen auf die zu
die wissen wie sie aussehen die haben
wir wissen wie sie kommen
es ist faktisch ist es in meinem leben
so dass jede weniger so aussehen dass
die viel gefährlicher ist ebenfalls die
vielen eher haben an der angst
aufgewachsen sind das sind angst bei
sind sozusagen
und wir wissen die gewalt hat ja werte
ganz vorn aber oftmals wären da wo die
angst selbst und seinen andererseits ist
das ausschalten von gewalt auf der einen
seite ist es aber so dass die angst
sendung die funkelnden sozialen da
blitzt es in der funkel das und die
fähigkeit das über zu überwinden macht
es letztendlich aus und wenn man diese
menschen erlebt dann sagen wir immer in
unserem sagen du merkst im gespräch da
hat man ganz kurze zündspulen und merkst
der ist unheimlich verletzlich die
verletzbarkeit die narzisstische
kränkung die dahinter sofort auftaucht
und ich bin auch belanglos fähig aber
daher ist die zündschnur länger also ich
kann vieles noch irgendwo ertragen und
so weiter sind menschen die können
halter zurückweisungen zugefügt nicht
alle bringen was ihnen bei noch mal her
irgendwas in baja im gefängnis mit viel
aufwand und so weiter gehen sind die
gesellschaft die gesellschaft ist ja
heute so gestrickt dass man ihnen sagt
er muss stark sein muss ellenbogen
zeigen was ist ja wir haben ja der
gesellschaft indem er kämpfer eigentlich
wir übertragen das immer gerne sehen
ja und dann haben die eier abgeschnitten
und das soll kämpfen und so empfindet er
sich dann auf der friede müssen ja
müssen ja nach der entlassung oftmals
wenn sie wenig intelligent sind wenn sie
über nichts anderes als ressource
verfügung als ihren körper sehr stark
ist und mit dem sie sich auskennen
müssen sie ja in die viertel zurück in
den gewalt und die die fähigkeit gewalt
auszuüben gefragt sind umgehen können
mit gewalt also ines abzutrainieren
ist im grunde völlig falsch weil sie
weil sie am ende dort wo sie wieder
hingehen müssen
der körper die kraft und der und die
gewalt die die ressource ist mit der sie
sich durchsetzen können nicht der kopf
und verstand aber sie reden hierzu über
den menschen so doch über diese menschen
als ob sie in einem gewissen
verhaltensmuster gefangen sind in das
sie auch wieder zurück müssen haben sie
denn gar keine wahl sich dagegen zu
entscheiden
natürlich hatte sich zu bessern
natürlich am menschen immer die wahl
sich dagegen zu entscheiden und es gibt
ja auch beispiele dafür dass menschen
die aus dem gefängnis entlassen werden
plötzlich in einen kontext hineinkommen
glück haben eine arbeit bekommen
vielleicht jemanden finden den sie
lieben kinder haben und männer die
kinder haben verhalten sich anders als
männer die keine haben in der regel weil
sie verantwortung übernehmen müssen weil
sie ihre umgebung nicht verwüsten und
verwahrlosen können natürlich gibt es
das immer aber das grundsätzliche
problem beim gefängnis sie haben ganz
richtig gesagt ist das ist auf der einen
seite dafür da ist das gesund wird also
eine tat gesühnt würden auf der anderen
seite soll es resozialisieren im
mittelalter gab es die spiegelung der
strafen für all das was man getan hatte
gab es einen spiegel in der strafe hand
abhacken oder tv genau wisse ja wie name
ist ein dass das verschwundene ist das
ist aber nicht so wäre die
resozialisierung sozusagen die einzige
ratio des strafvollzuges dann müsste es
für jede tat die gleiche strafe geben es
ist aber nicht so wir stufen genau ab
ein diebstahl bild anders bestraft als
totschlag oder mord und es geht am ende
eben auch also im strafrecht ist immer
noch der gedanke der vergeltung
enthalten und aus diesem dilemma gibt es
irgendwie kein ausweg weil die
gesellschaft auch will das vergolten
wird das ist ja vielleicht ein paradox
das gefängnis soll vergolten und
gewässer geraten und das ist schwierig
das zusammenzubringen
ich möchte auf etwas eingehen das schien
unglaublich interessant was sie gesagt
haben sie zeigen jetzt wieder hier in
diesem bild an diesem film die
muskelmänner die starken menschen das
sind ja unsere bilder des bösen der
muskuläre und vielleicht auch der fremde
mann sarkozy die eigentlichen straftäter
diesen vielleicht ganz schwach wir sind
ganz klein
die haben ganz andere gesichter was mich
zu der frage führt haben wir vielleicht
ein ganz falsches bild des bösen im kopf
wenn sie mit einer fernsehkamera in den
knast gehen was machen
in den letzten 20 jahren schon einige
teams dann finden sie genau diese
protagonisten jungs die sozusagen da
setzen und sagen okay ich kann mich
zeigen ich stehe zu dem und die hat auch
ganz andere erwartung an das haben die
den klassen besser aushalten ein
stückweit diejenigen sozusagen die nach
nichts aus sehen der hat die noch nicht
mal als geschenk erhalten können die
haben die meisten die wappen der
schlappen die handtücher usw
diese kleinen sage mal erbärmlichen
kreaturen oder sonst was
die kriegen sie ja schlecht von den
kammern mal die haben nicht das gefühl
dass sie irgendwas her zu weisen haben
oder so und das habe die erschreckend
größere zahl eigentlich der verdi töten
das sind menschen die angezündet weil
wie er vom weg gehen wollen die freundin
ich das wollte was sie warten weil sie
das ist also haus im endeffekt hast du
weg wollten die banal
das sind noch nicht mal die killer die
irgendwo mit klarem nüchtern und kalten
eiskalten verstand unterwegs gewesen
sind sondern es sind im endeffekt sage
ich mal effekt zerfressener kleine
geister denen irgendwo jemand nur wusste
banalität brauchte um die halt eben zu
einem überschäumenden aggression zu
bringen und das ist das was ich häufig
sehr vielen fehler häufiger ja und das
ist auch spielt heute eine rolle bei
denen sie haben am anfang gesagt wird es
mutig da irgendwelche dinge einzufliegen
es ist mutig sich das leben zu nehmen
das ist viel leichter wenn 150 leute mit
ihr gemeinsam im flieger sitzen
oder ist es nicht vielmehr sogar dass
man sich so interpretiert hat dass du
diese aufgabe ganz anderes als wenn du
alleine in einem flieger sitzen
ist die entscheidung sich das leben zu
nehmen wenn du allein auf dem dach steht
ist viel viel schwieriger als wenn du
den gürtel um heinz ist bis 25 leute im
hintergrund sagen das ist jetzt wieder
wenn du im flugzeug steht ich sehe immer
nur kleine geister die sie gescheitert
sind in ihrem leben die in ihren studien
gescheitert wenn es die nicht
weiterkamen der gesellschaft wie
ausgegrenzt wurden oder ausgrenzung
zumindest subjektiv
so erfahren haben selbst wenn sie
intellektuelle gewesen sind oder sowas
ausgrenzung mit nicht teilhaben so dass
wir haben immer gesagt das symptom das
dass das ja dass das kleine nichts des
kleinen körperlich kleinen auch aber
dass das kleinen seligen der immer
zurückgestoßen wird auf seine kunst aber
er braucht muss ich gleich mal haken
denn wenn ich ein barockes theorie und
sein denken war gewalt richtig verstehe
dann sein einsatz ihr der zu sagen es
geht gar nicht darum dass diese menschen
gekränkt war dass sie vielleicht nicht
richtig teile erwarten sondern gerade
der kleinen biedermann setzt man ihnen
die richtigen kontext und gibt ihnen die
richtigen möglichkeiten im
nationalsozialismus wie in stalinismus
geschehen ist dazu genau auch fähig das
heißt es gar nicht die geschichte der
kränkung sondern der kontext des
handelns der uns zu gewalttätern werden
lässt ich glaube ich würde haben bausch
wird zustimmen
das erst mal diejenigen die kräftig sind
die voll aufgepumpte muskeln haben die
vor selbstbewusstsein strotzen und die
wissen dass sie sich gegen jedermann
durchsetzen können dass diese leute
zweck rational mit gewalt umgehen können
weil sie genau wissen als mittel zum
zweck ich weiß wie das funktioniert ich
weiß ich dass einsetzen kann
während die ihnen die das nicht können
aber trotzdem aggressionen haben oder
irgendetwas machen wollen sich auf
andere verfahren einigen müssen um sich
durchzusetzen natürlich eine
öffentlichkeit will man gerne das böse
möchte man gerne repräsentiert werden
als jemanden als einen menschen der
dunkel ist der muskulöse ist der ordinär
ist das ist es aber in der regel gar
nicht und am ende wenn man jetzt mal die
attentäter vom 11
september nimmt auf die auf das andere
beispiel komme ich gleich so kann man
doch sagen jemand der eigentlich ein
niemand ist kann ja auf unterschiedliche
weise mit seiner bedeutungslosigkeit
umgehen man kann sich betrinken
man kann sex haben man kann angeln gehen
man kann ganz verschiedene dinge tun
aber man kann auch aggressiv werden und
menschen sind eben verschieden es gibt
nicht den menschen derweil eher
ausgegrenzt wird so reagiert aber es
gibt menschen denen man sagen kann
einmal in deinem leben
da hast du etwas besonderes sein und
wenn du 150 menschen mitnimmst
anschließend bist du jemand der in
erinnerung bleibt oder das ist attraktiv
das kann auch aktiv sein kann hemmungen
überwinden dass man weiß einmal in
meinem leben werde ich nicht einfach nur
ein bedeutungsloser drogendealer sein
sondern ich werde jemand sein der etwas
großes für eine große sache getan hat
und viele menschen werden sich an mich
erinnern was die biedermänner angeht ja
ich glaube man muss nicht böse sein
am ende böses zu tun und da komme ich
nochmal auf das zurück was ich eingangs
gesagt habe wenn räume und situationen
eröffnet werden in denen ganz viele
menschen etwas tun was sie unter
normalen umständen nie tun würden wenn
das passiert dann gewöhnen sich menschen
relativ schnell zwei drei vier wochen
daran dass auch zu tun und werden es
irgendwann für normal halten und der
moralische referenzrahmen verschiebt
sich sie legen sie dann eine moral zu
recht himmler hat ja mal gesagt trotz
allem sind wir ja anständig geblieben in
der man das was man da tut in
übereinstimmung mit allen anderen tut
und bei den einsatzgruppen der nazis war
diejenigen die gesagt haben ich schieße
nicht und sind aus dem glied
herausgetreten das durften die ja das
waren diejenigen die sich nun konform
verhalten hatten in diesen in diesem
kontext werden alle anderen die in den
50er jahren wieder die kinder auf dem
schoß hatten und die gartenzwerge im
vorgarten die töteten und sie töteten
weil sie sich konform verhalten wollen
lassen sie mich das mal ganz konkret
machen weil wenn man ihre bücher liest
kommt mir eine geschichte in den seen
die geschichte von joerg g und wolfram
die in einem bus nach syrien fahren man
setzt uns drei dann zwei wochen lang den
erfahrungen die dort zu haben sind aus
und dann werden so jörg und wolfram
möglicherweise und zwar sehr schnell zu
menschen die genau das gleiche tun ist
dass ihr bild vom menschen und auch von
den ursachen von gewalt exzess ich
glaube jörg krone wolfram können sind da
sind sie haben möglicherweise ganz
verschiedene menschen gemeinsam ist
allen dass sie nicht wissen was es
bedeutet wenn man den hals abzuschneiden
das wissen sie nicht so jetzt fahren sie
dort hin und stellen sich den krieg als
ein computer animation vor möglicher
weit ich weiß es nicht
sie stellen sich das als geräuschlos
geruchlos und irgendwie als eine große
sache
vor die sie zu helden macht und kommen
sie da an und sehen sie nein krieg
bedeutet herr austretende dame ist
bedeutet blut es bedeutet geschrei ist
bedeutet vergewaltigung das alles kannte
sie vorher nicht
nun gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
wie man darauf reagieren kann man kann
entsetzt sein
menschen können traumatisiert werden
aber andere eben nicht
es wird nicht jeder durch gewalt
traumatisiert einige können gefallen
daran gewinnen manche werden sich daran
gewöhnen andere verrückt werden oder
manche eben weil sie es nicht können von
diesen leuten selber umgebracht werden
wenn sie zurückkommen
auch dann wird es sehr unterschiedlich
sein welche erfahrungen sie gemacht
haben es kann dazu führen wie etwa bei
meinem vater der wehrmacht soldat war
dass man zum pazifisten wird dass man so
schockiert ist von der von der sache
dass man überhaupt schon den anblick
eines revolvers nicht ertragen kann
es kann aber auch dazu führen dass
menschen auf eine weise frauen dass sie
in der in der friedlichen umgebung ist
gar nicht mehr aushalten es gibt nicht
diesen einen menschen der immer in einer
situation das gleiche tut es ist nicht
so aber worauf man sich einigen kann ist
dass in situationen die wahrscheinlich
in situationen der gewalt die
wahrscheinlichkeit groß ist dass alle
gewalttätig sind weil man sich nicht nur
konform verhalten will das ist ausdruck
der konformitätsdruck ist groß und die
menschen die aus freude töten ist das
ist eine minderheit also das problem
wird psychopathen das ist nicht das was
menschen in der regel tun wenn sie in
gewalt kontexte geworfen werden und so
ist auch das rätsel aufzulösen dass man
nach der gewalt wieder ein ganz normaler
mensch sein kann und kann liebenswürdig
sein und kann irgendwie in einer neuen
rolle schlüpfen weil alle in der
umgebung plötzlich friedlich sind und
man auch gar nicht mehr argumentieren
kann das was ich da gemacht habe war
normal das haben alle gemacht das würde
in einer friedlichen gesellschaft gar
keiner verstehen aber es hat was sind
denn die indikatoren für sie habe
ausgesagt jetzt bei banken passiert bei
manchen nicht gibt es nicht doch
psychologische anlagen indikatoren
vielleicht in der kindheit die sagen bei
dem wird es doch sehr viel
wahrscheinlicher
so oder so sich verhalten ich würde aus
meiner erfahrung klar ist schon dass es
menschen gibt da fällt es
vergleichsweise leicht dass sie vor
das sind das machen was sie wollen ich
bin hier unten und wenn ich den stores
noch bekomme der oder ich dann bin ich
schneller dabei hat ja gerne habe
sozialisation hat weil der einfach auch
früher gewalt erfahrungen hatte die
armen oder händen von uns gott sei dank
nicht hatte so das heißt ich glaube es
braucht unterschiedlichen aufwand um aus
ihnen oder mir eine killer zu machen
kann einen mörder zu machen
das ist letztendlich mit mit dem nötigen
druck oder mit dem nötigen kontext
gelingen kann dass wir letztendlich alle
drei und man im beispiel zu bleiben
bewaffnet irgendwie tritten und sei es
nur das heißt nur um unser eigenes leben
zu zu sowie werden heißt das ist ja
schon mal gemeinsam als schon mal
gemeinsam konstruktion sehr hilft aber
ich glaube dass es menschen gibt die
halt eben viel leichter und das gibt es
weise gewinnen geringfügigeren anlass
dazu gebracht werden können die aber
keiner seite eine hohe fähigkeit harman
so leute mit sich zu ziehen
es gibt immer sozusagen auf die geigen
also es gibt immer jemanden der es
versteht die da abzuholen diesen
sozialarbeiter immer wiederholen nicht
da hast du bist und manch einer wird
halt eben nah an der gewalt abgeholt und
medizin weiter weg von der gewalt
abgeholt ich glaube schon dass sp
schlägt vor in der gewalt bei menschen
gibt das habe etwas mit erfahrung zu tun
das hat auch etwas mit genetik und
epigenetik sogar zu tun und wenn wir
sehen woher momentan sozusagen die
kosten gewalttätigen personen handeln
denn herkommen dann kommen sie als
gegner unseres planeten unseres unserer
erde in denen es 30 wird sie 50 76
jahren also in der dritten vierten
generation nur gewalt erfahrungen gibt
es wird also weiter geht es über das
epigenetische funktioniert aus der
betrachtung dass wir sehen die genetik
sagen sie nur ganz kurz was das bedeutet
ist die normale für abo und halb die
genetik es sozusagen ein genetisch
funktionierender vorgang der dem teich
will heißen wenn jemand über drei vier
generationen in kriegsgebieten in gewalt
und blut aufgewachsen dass das
irgendwann diese kinder anders reagieren
als jemand das nicht hat dann ist das
auch eine rolle spielt neben der reinen
vererbung
natürlich ist es auch wichtig für
jemanden wenn man ein land wie
afghanistan nimmt seit den 70er jahren
krieg ununterbrochen dass menschen die
dort leben damit auch umgehen müssen sie
müssen das lernen sie müssen gewalt
techniken erlernen sie müssen
misstrauisch sein sie müssen sich
umdrehen und sie müssen annehmen dass
der nächste der nicht in der
nachbarschaft wohnt ihr feind sein
könnte könnte
und weil das so ist stellen sich alle
auf gewalt ein und natürlich muss man in
einer situation die unüberschaubar ist
möglicherweise gewalt ausüben bevor es
andere tun und dann ist es dann ist es
klar dass so etwas entsteht was ich
kultur der gewalt nennen würde es gibt
keine kultur der gewalt an sich die zu
bestimmten kulturen gehört aber durch
langjährige gewöhnung an gewalt
entwickeln menschen eine andere kultur
im umgang mit gewalt etwa wenn sie die
russland die beschäftigung mit russland
ich würde sagen russland ist aufgrund
der jahrzehntelangen schrecklichen
erfahrungen mit exzessiver gewalt eine
misstrauens gesellschaft menschen sind
misstrauisch vertrauen institutionen
nicht und sie vertrauen auch nicht
fremden zunächst und das funktioniert
anders und deshalb glaube ich ist das
ist das ein wichtiges element wenn man
verstehen will warum manche menschen
gewalttätiger sind als andere sind aber
hätte wenn das stimmt was sie beide
sagen dann können wir ja eine sehr
unangenehme und dunkle frage nicht
vermeiden wir sind derzeit einer
geschichtlichen situation wonach
deutschland im vergangenen jahr alleine
eine million menschen gekommen sind 76
prozent davon männer und meistens junge
dh sie haben ihr leben lang in
verheerenden gewalt verbissen gelebt was
bedeutet das für sie auch präventiv und
in der richtigen ansprache mit diesem
problem denn man will diese menschen
nicht dämonisieren muss ihnen
andererseits aber auch gerecht werden
und den erfahrungen entsprechen die sie
selbst biografisch gemacht haben
wir haben kein misstrauen geregelt
ganz am anfang gesagt das erste bild
meines lebenspartners misstrauen
gegenüber allem fremden und vieles von
dem was wir also das ist kurz das
problem wie lange wir uns mit misstrauen
erlauben im umgang mit diesen menschen
zu sagen wir misstrauen stilisieren
sogar aus politischen absoluten
absehbaren konnten werden gehen diese
menschen draußen halten und werden das
problem größer größer machen muss machen
ich glaube je schneller wir diese
menschen jede für sich
und da ist jeder von uns gefragt was
soll's machen das ist ja das was wir
ohnehin schon seit 30 40 jahren in
unserem land gelernt haben die im
prinzip finde es gut aber andere kannst
machen ja also bei mir nicht so weil wir
nicht alles machen dass wir jemanden an
die hand nehmen oder weißen komplizierte
der müssen wir zeigen oder frosch die
locken projekt muss man ganz klar
auszudrücken aber so die meisten sind
guten willens und sind hergekommen weil
sie sich an das leben vorstellen und
dann müssen wir sagen okay geben die
hand und zeigt in dein leben
das ist das leben für das bistum ihr
hergekommen
wenn wir das nicht tun wenn wir zulassen
dass diese menschen diese jungen männer
hat sich sozusagen in ihrer eigenen
parallelwelt sonst weiterhin
sozialisieren haben ja richtig problem
an der backe dass sie mir diesen völlig
zu aber dazu gehört auch dass man dass
man menschen die mit extremer gewalt
aufgewachsen sind die misstrauisch sind
und die schnell zur gewalt greifen sagt
das ist das leben hier dass wir haben du
kannst teil von dem leben werden
aber wenn du nicht einen nicht an regeln
hält gibt es ärger das ist etwas was was
kulturell überhaupt nicht verschieden
ist das versteht jeder mensch egal aus
welchem kontext da kommt dessen regeln
und wenn die gebrochen werden die regeln
gibt es ärger was das problem ist glaube
ich dass wir uns in einer einer ordnung
eingerichtet haben die extrem
zivilisiert ist wo der staat nicht
martialische auftreten was wohl die
polizei abgerüstet ist das schätzen wir
ja alles in unserem alltäglichen umgang
auf der straße das funktioniert aber
nicht in einem augenblick wo männer
auftreten die gewohnt sind dass
konflikte mit extremer gewalt
ausgetragen werden und die staatsgewalt
damit eigentlich nicht umgehen kann wir
läuten keine verwarnung verweise
ausspricht die sie die sie auch zu
spüren bekommen sie merken wenn ich das
noch mal machen wird das richtig
unangenehm für mich wir müssen auch
darüber nachdenken ob unser ordnungs
unsere unsere ordnung und unsere
sicherheitsapparate mit denen wir
aufgewachsen sind ob sie noch den der
realität entsprechen in der wir jetzt
leben
auch das müssen wir uns glaube ich
überlegen auch wir müssen nämlich der
sicherheit weil das ist wichtiger punkt
natürlich auch gesellschaftlich
wahnsinnig rede man ist das ist ja
letztlich ein appell zur aufrüstung der
gesellschaft zu einer
sicherheitspolitischen solidität die
deutschland oder vielleicht die schweiz
derzeitig hat aber es gibt ja noch ein
anderes problem heraus arbeitet in einer
institution in der jede regel jeder
regelbruch sanktioniert wird in der es
ein großes regiment der sicherheit gibt
und eines gibt es dort genau nicht was
er bausch der wichtigkeit nämlich
vertrauen das vertrauen gegenüber dem
anderen das gefängnis seinen misstrauens
raum gibt es da ein bedingungslos
zwischen sicherheits gerüsten und
sanktionen androhen und dem was wir am
dringendsten brauchen nämlich vertrauen
gegenüber dem andern
also ich glaube es ist ein zusammenhang
gibt zwischen der durchsetzung des
staatlichen gewaltmonopols und im
vertrauen vertrauen beruht darauf hat
niklas luhmann gesagt dass man morgens
aus dem haus geht ohne ohne befürchten
zu müssen ausgeraubt oder getötet zu
werden
das ist so selbstverständlich dass wir
darüber gar nicht nachdenken wir gehen
morgens aus dem haus und denken darüber
nicht nach jemand der aus afghanistan
kommt oder aus manchen gebieten
russlands geht anders morgens aus dem
haus und das bedeutet etwas wenn wenn
man nicht im stande ist das staatliche
gewaltmonopol unter allen umständen
überall durchzusetzen ja dann erzeugt
man auch in einer gesellschaft die das
bislang nicht hatte
das gibt es ja wir können das ja nicht
weg reden in manchen
in manchen regionen stadtvierteln in
deutschland so ein unsicherheitsgefühl
und wenn ein unsicherheitsgefühl
auftritt ob es eingebildet ist oder
tatsächlich spielt gar keine rolle
menschen die sich einbilden haben ist
dann auch das unsicherheitsgefühl dem
kann man nur begegnen indem man einen
raum schafft indem man wieder soziologe
simmel das gesagt dass ich mit höflicher
nichtbeachtung begegnen kann
es müssen sich nicht alle integrieren es
müssen nicht alle so leben wie ich das
will
aber was gelingen muss ist dass wir uns
mit höflicher nichtbeachtung im alltag
begegnen können
und dafür ist voraussetzung sine qua non
ist das staatliche gewaltmonopol dass es
durchgesetzt werden kann das heißt nicht
dass irgendwo martialisch aufgerüstet
wird das heißt nur dass wenn regeln
übertreten werden kann ich ganz sicher
sein als bürger ich kann ganz sicher
sein ist das sanktioniert wird
auf welche weise auch immer und wenn das
wenn bürger das gefühl haben wir kennen
das aus vielen amerikanischen
großstädten da geht die polizei gar
nicht mehr hin
das soll die leute selber lösen da
sollen die selber dann sind es die armen
die opfer davon das sind die arm und
diejenigen die ausgegrenzten diesen
werten wie oft war von solchen von
solchen gewalt verhältnissen
deshalb glaube ich dass es einen
zusammenhang zwischen zwischen
sicherheit und vertrauen gibt den
sollten wir nicht gering schätzen wir
haben das alles in den 70er 80er jahren
in unserer gesellschaft so nicht
thematisieren müssen
es hat sich aber vieles geändert deshalb
muss auch das auch auf dem rad im
gefängnis und da gibt es viele regeln da
gibt es kein vertrauen überzeugt sie das
denn was er was er barocks gesagt es
wäre ja so wie wir sagen wir brauchen
letztlich ein sicherheitsgefühl wie es
ein gefängnis gewährleisten kann
im gefängnis und das geben was sie
gesagt haben im gefängnis ist die mist
bauen
das misstrauen ist der institutionell
heißt es ist der dbs ist die
organisation des gefängnisses ist so
organisiert ist und sagt ihr seid die
hallen wie es unter anderem wir machen
unter kontrollierten bedingungen einen
weg auf einen stark also einen schritt
auf den anderen zu misstrauen und
trotzdem den kopf wenn was nicht ist
unter kontrollierten bedingungen
begegnen wir uns das nennen wir dann
halt weil so resozialisieren kann ich ja
nur wenn die soziale kontakte mit ihm
die bauern machen dass nicht die waffen
machen das nicht sondern ist ein klarer
unter kontrollierten bedingungen gerade
bei dem beispiel dass mir nicht gefallen
hatte nehmen was sie gesagt haben ist
dass diese menschen ich beispielsweise
in afghanistan gelebt haben ich war vor
allem gegangen war
zum hass man noch 30 jahre wieder nach
dem krieg und hab gesehen wie sich diese
menschen mit diesen menschen sich
verändert haben zum thema vertrauen hat
sich das erste mal dabei hat der afghane
mir gesagt die packt ihr vergebens bei
mir ich werde mit meinem leben stehe ich
dafür dass sie das überleben gastrecht
und ich konnte dann unruhig den malen vw
bus schlafen
heute würde ich das nicht mehr tun wir
heute wieder einnehmen als sie haben
über 40 jahre als ich gedacht hatte mit
vorne umgebracht aber das ist nicht so
dass diese menschen die hierher kommen
sagen wir wir wer wir die erleben dort
regelmäßig dass gewalt und was sagt man
das sanktionieren von starken gibt hat
sie von gewaltmonopol bedeutet sie haben
natürlich verschiedene der eine hat das
in der nähe ja also es gibt verschiedene
konkurrierende systeme die um das
gewaltmonopol staat konkurrieren aber
sie machen alle viel heftigere
erfahrungen mit mit gewalt als wir uns
das vorstellen können es ist und
insofern ist diese behauptung also
brauchen sozusagen also eine bessere
struktur die noch mehr als wir das
glauben sie mich falsch verstehen dass
nämlich das noch gar nicht glauben
also ich glaube auch nicht dass wir
weniger aufgerüstet haben ich sehe heute
beispielsweise ich habe eine
französische polizei und 68ern ende der
60er anfang der 70er in paris erleben
sie waren hoch aufgerüstet diese gehe
mal los möchte sobald mehr als fünf
leute zusammen standen dann politisch
diskutiert wir haben das vergessen wir
haben da eine gewisse zeit mal sozusagen
abgerüstet und momentan erlebe ich das
wieder aufrüsten dieser gesellschaft
dass man sagt wir brauchen eine
wehrhafte gesellschaft die frage ist wer
macht es für uns wehrhaft ist glaube ich
und da bin ich wieder mal ein thema ich
kann das gewaltmonopol anderen
überlassen
aber ich kann auch im moment jeder von
uns muss ein stück weit das machen wir
haben das thema zivilcourage hin zu
gucken jemandem die hand zu geben unter
kontrollierten bedingungen sondern
ich kann sich auch die theorien zu sagen
das interessiert mich nicht aber anderen
muss ich die chance geben weil wir
gerade das auch zu tun ohne dass wir sie
für bekloppte wurden verstrahlt
aber das ist sicher an einer
gefährlichen kehre gerade wie es scheint
einerseits gibt es die zivilcourage
andererseits gibt es die selbst
bewaffnung beispielsweise deutschland
rasen die zahlen der waffenscheine und
der selbst nach oben bald dieses gefühl
nicht mehr da ist also ist dass die
kehre an der sie gerade die gesellschaft
sie haben zum beispiel auch in das ist
der punkt in den den ich mit ihnen den
ich eigentlich meinte ich meine nicht
dass afghanen die hierher kommen dass
die eine andere sicherheitsstruktur
brauchen weil die das nicht gewohnt sind
das habe ich nicht gemeint was ich meine
ist dass einwanderer die in diese
gesellschaft kommen wir mit völlig
anderen kontext konfrontiert worden
waren
die eben sehr gewalttätig gewesen sind
dass sie irgendwie einen begriff davon
entwickeln müssen was diese gesellschaft
zusammenhält und wer sie wie sie schützt
uns am beispiel deutlich zu machen
in berlin neukölln in bestimmten
arabischen milieus lösen die probleme
die die männer ihre probleme deshalb
selbst weil sie der auffassung sind der
deutsche staat bestraft und gewalt nicht
hart genug das hat gar nichts damit zu
tun dass diese leute einfach die ordnung
nicht respektieren sie doch einfach ist
zu lasch das regeln wir unter uns oder
friedensrichter die in einem viertel die
probleme lösen
nun wissen wir aber gar nicht ob etwa
die frauen deren probleme da von
irgendwelchen leuten gelöst werden ob
die das so wollen meint punkt ist ganz
einfach dass ich der auffassung bin dass
der staat die hoheit über die lösung
dieser probleme nicht aufgeben kann das
bedeutet nicht dass der martialisch sich
aufrüsten muss aber dass wenn frauen
malträtiert werden wenn menschen
überfallen werden dass die polizei da
auch noch hingeht dass sie in die
viertel hinein fährt und das wird bei
den bei den leuten die da die da ein
wandern im am ende auch zu der
überzeugung führen dieser start der ist
auch für unseren schutz dar
der schützt auch uns das problem ist dr
überall in diesen vierteln wo die
gangster die macht übernehmen ist die
arm und das insbesondere die einfahren
da die opfer von diesen gangstern sind
und deshalb bin ich finde ich einen
anhänger des staatlichen gewaltmonopols
tag durchgesetzt werden muss weil wir
das nicht wollen dürfen dass das so ist
ich gebe dir vollkommen recht dürfen
keine habe über viel über
parallelgesellschaften denn wir sie aber
sehenden auges zu lassen
er hat das wir viertel aufgegeben was in
amerika kennen dafür zahlen ich werde
nicht werden wir das aufkleben
dann lassen wir es dass auf keinen fall
das darf nicht sein und es ist auch
beispielsweise was man dazu auch ein
feld dass ich natürlich beispielsweise
karl den letzten anderthalb jahren
setzten im letzten jahr haben wir ja
innerhalb unserer institution und es
wird ja auch ministeriell mittlerweile
auch attestiert haben wir große probleme
mit dem menschen aus nordafrika also
damit rechnen müssen eigentlich nach der
nomenklatur das wieder abgeschoben
werden hier leben viele die sind auf dem
weg von marokko libyen und so weiter die
haben den türkischen gefängnissen
gesessen
die haben den bulgarischen gefängnissen
gesessen ja mit romanischen gefällt ist
dass sie habe sie über einen langen weg
gemacht
dieser weg hat dazu geführt hat wirklich
dass sie uns natürlich in unserer
reaktion auf fehlverhalten mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr richtig ernst nehmen
aber was soll das jetzt her und aber das
ist nicht weil sie weil dann ging es
damals es ist nicht weil sie originär
böse gewesen wären sondern weil sie
natürlich sagen die armee wolle nicht
mehr zurück auf gedeih und verderb das
sind junge menschen wenn wir uns wieder
auf den weg zurück machen ist unser
leben verwirkt und wir waren schon mal
da wir hatten schon mal gern mit dem
fuss im paradies und so leicht lassen
wir uns nicht mehr weg bringen das ist
ein riesenproblem
und diese leute gehen hohe risiken
eingehen selbst verletzende art und so
weiter und führen uns an grenzen dessen
dass wir sozusagen schaffen wo wir
einfach sagen wir stehen davor und
jungen das fehlt trotzdem hat darin dass
ich noch mal im gesehen ja sagen wie
schnell sozial relevanten politisch
relevant die frage nach der frage ist
das böse männlich wird wir haben ein
aspekt glaube ich noch nicht ausreichend
erklärt oder behandelt nämlich die
schiere tatsache dass es eine
parallelgesellschaft der gewalt gibt
dass es nämlich ausschließlich männer
sind
90 prozent der straftaten werden vom
ändern bedarf 90% bis 95 prozent der
gefängnisinsassen wenn das jetzt alles
stimmt was sie sagen und ich sehe auch
eine große einigkeit in ihren analysen
woher kommt das dann mit dem man es ist
einfach nur deswegen weil der mann in
unserer selbstbeschreibung immer als
handelnder wahrgenommen wird oder ist es
etwas im man selbst vielleicht doch in
seiner biologie der ihn gewalt mehr sein
lässt also ich glaube schon dass wir
also hinter unserer neurobiologie
einfach wirklich meine anderes der nato
haben im bios haben wir sozusagen andere
verschaltung ja wir wissen dass in
männlicher nachkommen mensch das baby
hat die ersten drei monate des
testosteron von und erwachsene
dann fällt das wir ein also unser gehirn
wird in den ersten drei monaten in
testosteron gebadet
ja das heißt wenn er auspacke
plastizität da wo sich die
bahnhersteller zwischen spiegelneuronen
emotionalität angstzentrum usw werden
wir gebadet soll das ist eine der zweite
ist es wird uns natürlich auch vorgelebt
das heißt da als kerl kannst du nur
bestehen wenn du auch irgendwo ein
gewisses dominanz verhalten an den tag
denkst du bist auch von unserer
erziehung sind wir diejenigen wir
schützen und wir sind ja die väter wir
haben die väter wolle die männerrollen
würdig von kindesbeinen mit dann auf den
weg gekriegt das stell dich davor du
stehst dafür du schützt seine brut deine
kinder und so weiter und so fort das ist
auch noch dazu sicherlich und das führt
dann halt eben ein stück weit dazu
glaube ich dass wir
wir sind doch anders als frauen reden
durfte frauen können auch böses tun aber
sie reden sich klar ist nach rheda usw
oder sie bedienen sich an das wütende
wandels oder sonstwas watt ist
jedenfalls erlebt aber ich glaube schon
dass wir eher auf auf verletzungen
unsere integrität oder ausgrenzungen und
so weiter als männer reagieren als das
frauen das ist einfach wenn ich jetzt
höre würde ich sagen die beste
gewaltprävention unserer gesellschaft
ist die emanzipation man muss den man
aus dieser rolle befreien um ihn weniger
gewaltsam werden zu lassen
die frage ist ob man das zulassen werde
dass sie da vorhaben
man kann ja vieles man kann ja vieles
wollen aber es ist immer noch an der
tatsache dass in den meisten
gesellschaften auf dieser welt männer
polizisten sind dass männer waffen
tragen und und in armenien soldaten sind
in den meisten armeen dieser welt in
denen frauen dienen werden frauen nicht
im kampf eingesetzt und das männer über
all diese rollen spielen und man muss
tatsächlich würde ich ihnen zustimmen
sagen das wollen noch männer auch gibt
auch männer die das wollen männer wollen
nicht weg sondern sie wollen männer
sollen und aber das heißt dann auch
immer gewalttätig so wie sie es jetzt
darstellt gibt es eine sozusagen interne
verbindung zwischen gewaltanwendung und
männlichkeit sie unterstellen ja das
sozusagen es wünschenswert sei dass
gewalt aus unserem leben verschwindet
aber ich denke wir müssen uns einfach
damit abfinden dass ist gewalt gibt wir
alle können gewalttätig werden wir
können uns jede gewalttat vorstellen wir
haben aggressionen wir haben zwei
festigen können waffen bedienen
das können wir alles also ihr argument
lebt ja so von der prämisse eigentlich
ist die gewalt irgendwie etwas
schlechtes ist eine abweichung im
menschlichen fragen an ich muss die weg
und wie kriegen wir die welt wie kriegen
sie weg indem man den mann zivilisieren
ich glaube das ist eine illusion ich
finde es interessanter darüber
nachzudenken wie man die verhältnisse
systematisch so einrichten kann
dass männer sozusagen ihre ihre dominanz
bestreben anders ausleben können das
meine ich damit dass man in vierteln in
denen
das tor ungesteuerte aufgepumpte männer
für ordnung sorgen dass man da den start
rein schickt und das hat ja dazu geführt
dass in unseren gesellschaften männer so
wie wir mit der kraft des argumentes uns
auseinandersetzen können und uns nicht
mit der faust oder mit gewalt
durchsetzen müssen wären wir jetzt in
einen anderen kontext in dem es kein
staatliches gewaltmonopol gebe wo die
weltweit durch die blutrache
strukturiert würde müssten wir als
männer anders auftreten
das ist einfach mal ein faktum und
deshalb glaube ich hat das staatliche
gewaltmonopol natürlich dazu geführt
dass staaten ihre bürger fast larven
konnten beispiel nationalsozialismus
stalinismus aber es hat auch seit dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert dazu geführt
dass räume sicherungs räume geschaffen
wurden in denen wir uns so zivilisiert
einander begegnen wo er ist versteckt
hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen
widersprechen weil sie sagten wir haben
es geschafft kraft unserer argumentation
zu überzeugen und dort sich hören wir
auf uns zu glauben dass argumente
überzeugen könnten sollen
gesundheitliche baum geben indem werden
keine argumente mehr helfen
da muss halt einer dastehen mit dem
schild und knöpfen oder so also ich sag
mal ich bin auch nicht der überzeugung
dass emanzipation alleine uns weiter
bringt also ich gerade überlegt was wir
es gesagt haben wenn ich gerade sehe in
den letzten zehn jahren also gute einer
doch gottlob fortschreitenden
emanzipation gibt es plötzlich immer
mehr männer die in einen erweiterten
suizid tatsächlich nur erfahrung bringen
sondern auch gleich die kinder oder
solche frau zu verlieren ist bei vielen
männern die nationale investor king und
so weiter hat also im maximalen
verletzung szenario erweitert also
emanzipation toll aber viele an für
viele kommt sie zu früh viel lob sie
vorbei
das heißt man zieht nation alleine wird
das
nicht richten können das mal so zu sagen
ich glaube dass wir das wir um das war
sozusagen ein paar wochen schon die
struktur die uns den raum gibt indem wir
das ausprobieren dürfen nicht vergessen
bisher mit so ein gefängnis ist eine
struktur in der kann ich näher zu
jemandem hat zeugen gucken klar dass wir
brauchen aufbauen oder nicht und wie wir
den schritt zurück gehen
und wie in der regel treu passiert wäre
bei diesem experiment nichts das ist
anders als in der u-bahn anders auf
öffentlichen straßen und da wo wir
momentan ja die gewalt vermuten
und noch ein argument zur aggression
weil wir seit die aggression ist nämlich
alles spricht ein stück weiter für aber
aggression ist immer auch sag ich mal
geschichtlich der entwicklung des
menschen etwas gewesen wenn er etwas
verteidigen normalerweise wenn er etwas
verteidigen wollte an dem ihm etwas lag
dagegen hat ihr das gezeigt dieses
verhalten dass es gibt keine betrieb
kann aggressionstrieb und alters sondern
taube ist nicht wissenschaftlich in dem
moment wo er für etwas kämpft an dem in
etwas liegt es ist ein community
normalerweise ein kommunikatives signal
die saisonhalbzeit so eine bürste kriegt
ja dann muss man mit ihm reden und so
ist aber da aber oder kontrollierten
bedingungen das heißt dann darf mich
diese reaktion nicht schrecken wenn ich
mich jedes mal erschrecken wenn einer
das tut was er tun sollte was
nachvollziehbar aber wenn ich dann sage
hoch der schritt nicht aber dann muss
ich aber jetzt muss aber eine camperin
sozusagen bedeutet lasst das bitte sein
problem ganz kurz ich meine wir kennen
auch viele frauen denen etwas bedeutet
und die sofort einen hals bekommen und
die sehr sehr wehrhaft sind wenn es um
gewisse dinge geht genauso wie männer
aber der historiker und das ist eine
frage an den historiker der muss ja
darauf auch ein anderes bild haben es
gibt ja diesen satz und er ist auch sehr
war die kzs und gulags wurden von
ländern gebaut und bewacht und
exekutiert glauben sie das hätte in
einer zukunft genauso gut auch von
frauen ausgeführt werden können
ja warum denn nicht also diejenigen die
die kz geplant haben die sie entworfen
haben und die damit befasst war sie zu
überlegen wie die gewalt organisiert
werden muss waren ja selbst keine
anders aggressiven männer also einig man
und himmler waren ja hätten sich auf der
straße er nicht durchsetzen können
sondern waren schreibtischtäter die sich
mit ihren opfern die sie millionenfach
haben umbringen lassen ja gar nicht
konfrontiert haben aber in den lagern
selber sind ja auch frauen gewesen
natürlich gab's kz wächterin den
ravensbrück kampfes frauen kz in
auschwitz in bergen belsen die
gewalttätigsten und grausamsten wörter
sind oft frauen gewesen
also da daran glaube ich überhaupt nicht
das wenn frauen sozusagen die
befehlsgewalt über bestimmte dinge haben
das dann alles besser würde am ende sind
diejenigen die die gewalt organisieren
sie aber nicht ausüben ja nur menschen
die am schreibtisch sitzen und etwas
sich etwas ganz abstraktes vorstellen
wir schaffen die juden weg wir töten die
bourgeoisie
das sind ja keine einzelnen menschen die
darum gebracht werden das ist was völlig
anderes und da können männer und frauen
genauso auf gleiche weise umgehen wird
die haben jetzt auch sind ganz viele
dinge schon eingestimmt eine sache ist
mir glaube ich noch wichtig zu fragen
weil wir alle ein diffuses unsicherheits
und bedrohungsgefühl vielleicht derzeit
stärker mit uns tragen als in den
letzten jahren ihr buch heißt räume der
gewalt jeder raum hat auch eine schwelle
glauben sie dass unsere gesellschaft
derzeit in westeuropa auf eine neue
welle der gewalt tritt oder schon auf
dieser stelle steht also ich glaube dass
die gewalt in unser leben zurück kommt
dass sie war ja immer da sie ist latent
ja immer vorhanden auch der stadt roth
ja immer gewalt an obwohl wir sie im
alltag nie spüren wissen wir ja immer
dass wir bestimmte schwellen nicht
übertreten dürfen weil es sonst
funktioniert wurde also gewalt ist ja
immer teil unseres lebens selbst dann
wenn sie nicht ausgeübt wird
aber was jetzt noch gerade passiert ist
dass viele menschen den eindruck haben
dass er in bestimmten regionen in
bestimmten stadtvierteln
unter bestimmten umständen gewalt wieder
eine wichtige ressource geworden ist um
sich durchzusetzen das macht vielen
menschen angst dass das so ist und ich
glaube wir haben vergessen dass wir in
unserer aufgeklärten zu
realisierten humanen gesellschaft
deshalb so viel ausprobieren konnten
weil wir dieses gewaltmonopol auf eine
weise aus austariert haben dass das
überhaupt möglich war einen raum zu
öffnen dem wir experimentieren können
das schwule pärchen hand in hand über
die straße gehen können ist ein
experiment machen sie das mal in
russland ist überleben sie nicht wenn
sie im ausgang hand in hand als schwules
pärchen über die straße gehen und jetzt
machen leute die erfahrung räume die
sich geöffnet haben indem man denen man
experimentieren konnte werden durch
gewalttäter verändern und das ist das
ist das was ich gemeint habe damit dass
der staat die aufgabe hat den raum zu
schützen indem wir mit unseren
lebensform experimentieren können und
uns dabei einander ignorieren können
dass wir sagen können wir den anlass den
anderen so sein wie er will und die
gewalt zerstört diesen vertrauens raum
das ist ganz gut wir sind tatsächlich
mit der zeit am ende ich glaube habe
über räume der gewalt gesprochen wie wir
sie schützen was sie mit uns tun und ich
glaube wir haben auch ein gespür dafür
bekommen wie wichtig es ist sensibel für
gewalt zu sein sie zu beobachten und sie
auch zu sanktionieren
ich danke ihnen sehr herzlich für diese
stunde gemeinsam nachdenken und wünsche
ihnen auch zukünftig uns dass wir
möglichst ohne gewalt unterliegen
dankeschön so auch nächste woche widmen
wir uns wieder einen großen
menschheitsthema anlässlich einer neuen
folge des schweizer tatorts mit dem
titel freitod spricht barbara bleisch am
philosophischen stammtisch über das
brisante thema der beihilfe zum suizid
und fragt dürfen menschen ihren
todeszeitpunkt selber wählen wann ist
ein suizid wirklich selbst bestimmt und
wie ist mit dem phänomen des
sterbetourismus umzugehen
und wenn sie vom bösen noch nicht genug
haben dann erwartet sie jetzt eine
sternstunde kunst und zwar in film über
den niederländischen maler hieronymus
bosch der vor 500 jahren gestorben ist
so wie kein zweiter zu seiner zeit die
menschlichen abgründe ängste und
fantasien auf die leinwand zauberte viel
spaß damit
vielen dank
[Musik]